back in Washington President Trump is
continuing his aggressive response to
hurricane Harvey just tonight asking
Congress for seven point nine billion
dollars for Harvey recovery operations
tomorrow mr. Trump travels to Texas in
Louisiana to meet with victims and today
the president declared Sunday as a
National Day of Prayer for Harvey
victims mr. Trump is praising the
response of the area's hardest hit by
the storm the people of Texas and
Louisiana were hit very hard by a
historic flood in their response they
had taught us fallen lesson a very very
powerful lesson there was no outbreak in
crime there was an outbreak of
compassion only real beautiful strong
compassion and they've really inspired
us as a nation to be honest they've
inspired the world because the world is
watching for the latest on Harvey and
it's aftermath let's go to Steve
Harrigan in Orange Texas Steve Jessie
this is a pretty typical scene in Orange
Texas the house closest to the highway
might have three or four feet of water
damage further down you go to the
neighbor five or six feet by the time
you get to the end of the street some of
those houses are completely underwater
all day long we've been watching people
pull things out from these soaked houses
trying to save what they can out on the
sidewalk you'll see soaking wet couches
carpets even drywall this brown stinking
water seems to destroy almost everything
it touches this is tough work here to
try and clean it up and emotional work
as well more than 37,000 houses have
major structural damage from this
hurricane so the cleanup effort is going
to be huge and a lot of people still
don't know how bad it is we've seen
people come to the edge of the water
point down the road and say see that
third telephone pole down there that's
my house what you see there is nothing
nothing but water so a lot of people
have it very bad but they still don't
know how bad yet they can't get to their
houses there's 10 feet of water in the
way Jesse back to you thanks a lot Steve
let's now that Rick Leventhal in Vidor
Texas Rick
Jessie this town got a year's worth of
rain in four days and main street
remains underwater tonight the not just
River the the peak of that River the the
flood record was 13 feet today it
crested at 21 so 8 feet above the
previous record this town could not have
seen that coming
and just like much of Southeast Texas it
is dealing with some horrific conditions
here tonight there's a curfew in effect
the powers out the residents were lined
up at a nearby store all day trying to
get some basics water food that sort of
thing and there are people behind me in
neighborhoods that are basically islands
at this point there are some dry
stretches of Main Street leading that
way but in between there are these
massive areas that have been flooded so
earlier today we went out with some some
relief workers some volunteers and some
members of the Harrison Fire Department
from South from northeast Texas and they
had a high water vehicle there driving
through the through the floods towing a
boat on a trailer they go through the
dry areas through another flooded area
through another dry area to get to
another flooded areas the only way these
boats could get in there to then send
the boats in to pick up people their
pets bring them out put them back on the
truck and then drive them back out again
they've evacuated they does police chief
tells me 12 to 15 hundred people there
are some people who didn't want to leave
their homes
now our wishing they did some of those
people are now being rescued and the
police chief tells me that they're
moving from this recovery operation to a
law enforcement operation they have had
some looting issues here and they're
dealing with those as they continue to
hope that these waters recede a little
bit quicker than they are so far Jesse
unbelievable wreck thank you very much
president Trump hasn't left Washington
yet but he's already getting criticism
from the left for his trip to heart to
see Harvey victims in Texas and
Louisiana tomorrow we all talked about
how insensitive it was him not to
mention the victims in his first trip
tomorrow should not be to remake or redo
what he didn't do the first trip
tomorrow he ought to say we're making
immediate funding available we're going
to put FEMA people on the street to
handle debris he needs
coming with a proactive agenda rather
than a make up for the debacle he did
the other day so that's the new
narrative gutfeld that he blew it on the
first trip and now this is a makeup trip
is anybody believing that well you
shouldn't believe anything from Sharpton
there are five words for him shut up and
go away this is a guy who has lived his
life about himself what are the most
self-serving hustlers of our time he is
the exact opposite of what you see in
the streets of Houston and everywhere
it's funny
a traditional leftist like him are in
malfunction mode this is why you're
seeing them now blame Trump for this or
for that they're trying to find a
narrative that matches their grim
worldview because Harvey has destroyed
their worldview there's no more division
there's no more bigotry there's no more
racism a conflict you're all you're
seeing 24/7 is unity Americans all the
time working together so they go like
well what can we do now let's go after
Trump because that might work
yeah just another note about what what
Harvey has done one of the positive
things offers a contrast to things like
Twitter you know Twitter encourages
antagonism because it's not face-to-face
interaction so I can attack you or you
or you because we never actually know
each other you can't find one example in
Harvey coverage of negative human
interaction you can't find one because
it's face to face it's human you cake
there's nothing there's no antagonism
and it shows you the contrast between
why people have to talk to each other
rather than tweet at each other and it
also you know very quickly just to tack
onto Greg's point because I think you're
absolutely right and it's the difference
between how you view human nature yeah
so if you view human beings as senseless
and needy and incapable of thinking for
themselves and ultimately as bad people
who when they lose everything then they
will attack each other
you are a statist yeah however if you
are someone who believes that human
nature is ultimately good and people
will come together in the face of a
crisis well then you are a decent person
probably a libertarian and
my aunty China degrade relying on each
other you're relying on their neighbors
accepting the help but more than that
like reaching out and helping as many
people as they possibly can for the for
the sheer sake of helping people right I
guess Joel steamed that isn't on Twitter
huh he's actually I don't think he is
and I think he's been a really bad job
yeah well I'm sure you can't think of
one instance I mean the whole country is
talking about that as an instance and
then you say you know sell put
self-absorbed person for a second I
thought you talked about Trump but no
you're talking about Sharpton yeah
because we were talking about Sharpton I
think I think Trump gave a million
dollars I think Osteen might have been
mischaracterized okay because I don't
think anybody ever had all the facts on
that story I don't and Tyler Perry Tyler
Perry just gave what a quarter of a
million to Osteen so your story went up
in smoke
no that's know by his own admission he
says you know he was directing people to
the city and he didn't have the church
could have done it but you guys done a
better job I don't think that's the
story on a negative story I agree with
you that overwhelmingly it's been a
positive yeah Cory and and I think it's
so important for the country to hear
yeah those kinds of healing messages but
I don't think that it was fair to go
after Sharpton Oh Brenda Audrey says
something very yummy grand this is not
about a makeup trip this is about
helping people you helped Tawana Brawley
didn't he oh you're back to sharp yeah
Freddie fashion Mart remember that I see
well I think I got low to the crown
high-crime don't like riots people die
hey shoes the donations from Trump and
where they went to like that huge look
we're talking about he did donate a
million dollars of their own money we
don't know that the White House doesn't
know even we donated dollars Victor Jara
you don't want into a negative story
gonna run Borgan is income from his
personal that's all the only point of
doing that is to make it look like
he's not sharpton is cousin still a
taxes yeah but I mean we sure don't even
know about prices don't raise your hand
if you're surprised that al Sharpton is
again exploiting tragedy to raise his
personal profile which is diminishing I
mean this is what this is about
he's trying to latch on to a Travie T or
tragedy to regain relevancy here and my
question do you want and for Democrats
what can the president possibly be doing
more that he's not been doing over this
past week to help the victims of Harvey
well I think that it's clear and I think
that's what Sharpton was saying no make
it about helping people and an answer to
your question I think it's so
self-evident I don't want to be overly
critical because people have gone over
this point what he lacked you know what
if not I didn't watch on NBC if he
hadn't gone to the to the flutter if he
hadn't gone to Texas if he hadn't met
with the the governor of Texas and
relief workers if he had stayed in DC
which is what some liberals were begging
him to do just so they could criticize
him for that I mean in this situation
he does plenty of things where he hurts
himself this is not one of them and for
the people who are looking for drama and
trying to exploit political division for
their own game gain rather shame on
it'll be honest anything that president
Trump does she's going to be criticized
that is the way that this president is
being covered by the media slate and
publicly Hines like that is it will bits
late in publications like that were
already criticizing before the storm
even hit look you have both Governor
Abbott and governor Edwards of Texas in
Louisiana one a Republican one a
Democrat who have praised President
Trump in this administration's handling
of the storm in both very quickly
approving the disaster declaration
giving them the much-needed government
money that they need to help rebuild
their states and also just in the search
and rescue process as well as we had
mentioned president Trump also is
allegedly allegedly giving a million
dollars of his own money
what is our shirk been doing to help
them that's what I would like to know
I'm seriously what has he done wrong I
will show a ton of leadership
sighs exploiting tragedy to try to get
his face on TV I think that you're you
know it's interesting to watch you guys
you guys are so back on your heels on
this empathy issue because know who
absolutely any president is also a
manufactured by many
you can go hey if you recall would you
do it for president did you want him to
climb trees or rescue kitten No you know
what is empathy here's the thing Kennedy
if you tweet epic devastation I was out
there I went to the frontlines I'm hurt
and people know he did not go to the
frontlines
not about anybody trying to exploit
something is simply saying that was a
failure in terms of leadership not a
cynical moment it doesn't measure up to
what other presidents did 9/11 can I
know sure I know
but okay go ahead Greg I I said this
yesterday but president Trump's role in
this is not that important because what
you're seeing is a monumental shift in
the narrative of this country we have
been immersed in identity politics for
so long and what we're seeing is a
waking up we were coming out of this
horrible depression and I think it's
kind of monumental I don't think Trump
plays a huge factor as he didn't have to
because what you're seeing is it's so
important in Texas you are seeing
victims not acting like victims after
years of people embracing victimology
who aren't victims in this case you're
seeing real victims just getting it done
without acting like victims we're seeing
we're seeing a monumental turnaround now
that's a really good point and people
reclaiming their goodness yeah and and
not being told that because they might
have political differences they have to
hate each other right and they have to
shout at each other and they have to use
fascist tactics in order to shred each
other down there is none of that here
and I think that's why the left is
looking for something to manufacture in
order to drive a web they are there
doesn't need it also hasn't failed here
and that's why we're seeing the
desperation of the left because they're
grasping at straws to come up with
reasons how President Trump is not
handling this well case in point
milania's heals that's what they're
trying to do they're grasping at straws
he's doing a very good job and we should
be appreciative of that the guys on the
ropes you know in terms of in terms of
his inability to really and I think
that's what we owe you guys like shout
like people talk but I'm just let me
finish they say he's on the ropes in
terms of the
lack of empathy the fact that he didn't
go to the victims instead he goes to a
shelter you had created a father
narrative one is no one believes he live
is the example of ms dhoni
i see if you want to go ahead and say
that the first day you heard it on some
other show and then you repeated it the
second day i think you gotta go daddy
hard to finish this big government role
is harder to say the governor was seeing
you bigger
Oh see this is how messy this is Brutus
and the point I wanted to make to you
it's not me go to the Fox poll it's only
like a quarter of Americans who think
this president has empathy okay goes to
a FEMA and board and pull that out about
a hard-on
he's self-absorbed talking about himself
versus President Bush's look we can we
just absolutely something shouldn't talk
about the same I've been delighted okay
that's it okay now let's get to the
point where it matters if you are having
emergency surgery do you want a surgeon
who is a jerk who is the best surgeon or
do you want an average surgeon who has a
great website legitimate before we want
you want an excellent surgeon who's a
jerk not a terrible surgeon who's all
fuzzy you don't want that so the fact is
expecting empathy from Trump that's not
why he was elected it wasn't why he was
elected because he's supposed to be
effective that's all we hear about your
point all I'm saying is it was
self-absorption I'm going to do better
than Bush this is how I'm taking it
thank you we're going great Roz why our
lawn cares about feelings we care about
results will be